RONALD SMITH: What have
we learned?
Well, we've learned about the
atmosphere and the ocean, and
how they work.
The physical processes that go
on to make the ocean and
atmosphere, like we find
them on our planet.
We've also learned a little bit
about how they're changing
in time and what processes
are causing them
to change as well.
So in a nutshell, that's kind
of what we've learned.
And how did we do it?
This may not have been apparent
to you, but as I look
at the course, we've been
using three intellectual
approaches as we've gone
through this material.
Observation has been one,
a very important one.
Quantification, trying to get
numbers onto everything.
Amounts, numbers, and units.
And then logic, interpretation,
and
explanation.
Why are things the
way they are?
How do things connect?
How do physical principles
explain this phenomena, but
also that phenomena.
So observations, quantification,
and I guess
explanation are the themes, or
the approaches, that we've
used going through the course.
What can we do with this?
Well, that's not
so easy maybe.
On a kind of a trivial basis,
you could use the material of
this course to lead you into
more advanced courses.
If you need--if youwant to
chat with me about any of
that, I'd be more than happy
to talk to you about what
other courses are offered,
especially in G&G, which I
know the best. But also EVST,
maybe engineering as well has
some other courses.
So you can you know this is
an introductory course.
It's a survey course, and for
many it can serve as a good
foundation for doing more
advanced courses.
Another thing that you can do
with this that I think is fun,
I remember when I was a student,
I loved to take
material I learned in one course
and see if I could fit
it together with things I was
learning in other, seemingly
unrelated courses.
Find ways in which
they connect.
A few of you over the course
have mentioned to me examples
where you've seen the material
in here kind of match up in a
certain way with other courses
you are taking, have taken, or
maybe you'll find out this will
happen in the future as
you take other courses.
But that's really important
because this stuff is not
meant to have sharp boundaries
around it.
It's not a body of knowledge
that's controlled and fenced
off from other disciplines.
It's supposed to be
just the opposite.
A subject that has a lot of
connections, whether it's
economics, or engineering,
or biology.
I hope you'll try to find those
connections as you go forward.
So I think this course you can
take a course in music
appreciation.
Or you can take a course
in nature appreciation.
Maybe this is a course in nature
appreciation, where you
learn a bit about how to observe
and appreciate things
that are going on.
Now some would take the other
side of the argument.
Some would say, no, no if I
approach environmental studies
from a physical or a quantified
point of view, it
loses--some of nature loses its
appeal to me, its wonder,
its beauty, and so on.
Now I've never found
that to be true.
I got into this field because
I appreciated what was going
on around me in nature.
And I've found that only
deepening as I've studied it
quantitatively.
It's true that when I see
something happening now I can
understand, at some level,
why it's happening.
But that only leaves another
thousand mysteries beyond that
of things that I don't
yet understand,
but wish that I did.
So in a sense this I don't
think will limit your
appreciation of what goes
on in the out-of-doors.
It will just perhaps change a
little bit the approach you
take to understanding it.
And the last one I have on
my list here is that this
material, I think, is important
because there are
some important political and
moral questions that face us
as individuals and as a society
for which you need
some scientific knowledge in
order to understand what
direction we should be going.
You know this idea I'm sure
you've heard this in other
courses but this idea of a
common, something that's
shared by a number of people.
In the old days in
New England, it
was the town green.
Like what's now New Haven Green,
and all these old New
England villages, was a common
space and people could bring
their cows and their sheep
to graze there.
Now that didn't last too long,
because after a while they
were too many sheep and too
many cows to--they would
overgraze a single common
area like that.
But the point is, it's a shared
area where everybody
benefited from it, but everybody
had to take some
responsibility for it as well.
Well now, the atmosphere
and the ocean are
the commons, right?
We all derive benefits
from it.
We all pollute it in some way.
And so we have to take
responsibility for that.
And that's the basis for these
moral and political questions
that I alluded to.
Having a scientific
understanding of that system
may help us to make the
right choices there.
So that's some of the
why's and what's we
did during the term.
I want to finish up by spending
the next few minutes
talking about some
common themes.
And I passed out this sheet of
paper which lists some, and
I've--that's up on the
server as well.
I tried to scan through, the
other night, the things--kind
of the physical principles that
we've run across in this
course more than once.
We didn't always state them in
the same way sometimes they
were, because they had such
a different context.
They almost seem like a
different physical principle.
But today I want to spend
some time trying
to tie these together.
Because I don't know I want to
OK, agreed there's a lot of
individual little facts and
figures that you dealt with
throughout the course.
But I've never looked
at it that way.
I've always looked at it as kind
of a continuum where we
could learn a few physical
principles, and use them over
and over again to solve
related or maybe even
seemingly unrelated problems
during the semester.
And that's what I want
to emphasize today.
I don't think I've done a good
enough job during the term
emphasizing those common themes,
so my last day here is
an attempt to repair my errors
for the semester by paying
more attention to these
common themes.
The first, which is not
even on the list,
would be physical units.
So we talked about units earlier
in the course, and
we've had to use them every time
we were doing any kind of
a quantitative calculation.
And I hope you've come to
appreciate them as much as I
have. Not only did they provide
us a common language
when I say the air density in
this room is 1.2 and leave it
there, that conveys
essentially zero
information to you.
Unless I put the units onto
that, kilograms per cubic
meter, it has no meaning.
So the units are really
essential in how we talk to
each other and convey
information.
They also have this magical
property of allowing us to
check our work, to see whether
a formula that we're plugging
numbers into, or that we've
derived in some way, is
physically consistent, by seeing
if the units work out.
So it's really a wonderful
set of things.
And if you're not fully up to
speed on that by now, I
recommend that you work a bit
on that, because that will
improve everything that you do
in this course and in another
physical science courses.
Having a more of a facile
understanding and a adeptness
of using units will certainly
improve all of your work and
your thinking.
So let's go on then to the first
one that I do have on
this list, the properties
of air.
And of course, density and how
it's related to other things
is important.
And we found that air
is a perfect gas.
p equals rho r t.
And so we know that we can
solve that equation for
density if we want.
p over r t.
And that shows us that density
is a function of pressure and
temperature.
At constant pressure, if you
heat up the air it'll expand
and the density will
become less.
At constant temperature, if you
add pressure to it the air
will compress and the density
will become greater.
So we had to know that, and
that's so important in all of
the things we did.
And that gas constant, which
appears in the perfect gas
law, is different
for every gas.
Remember that.
And that can be found by
dividing the universal gas
constant by the molecular
weight for
that particular gas.
So the other thing we needed
to know is heat capacity.
How much heat is stored in
a chunk of air at a given
temperature?
And that's important for how the
winds transport heat, how
air cools and warms as it
rises and sinks in the
atmosphere, we used it
over and over again.
OK, so any questions on
properties of air?
Properties of water.
Now the list is longer.
Why is the list longer for
water than for air?
Very simple.
Air, in the realm in which we
experience it, conditions here
on earth, is always a gas.
You can compress
it to a liquid.
I suppose, with enough
compression and cooling, you
might even reduce
it to a solid.
But we never see air in anything
other than the
gaseous state, so all we need
are those three little things
that I mentioned for air.
But for water, we find it in
all three phases on normal
conditions on earth.
Gas, liquid, and solid,
that is to say, ice.
So we have to have some
information about its density
in the gaseous state--in
the liquid state.
And for the oceans, we've
learned they're dependent on
salinity and temperature.
We need to know the heat
capacity of water.
How much heat can be stored
in water at a certain
temperature?
And then everything else here
has to do with phase changes.
So at what temperature does it
freeze from liquid to solid?
And that was actually slightly
dependent on salinity.
Remember, at full ocean
salinity, the freezing point
is not zero Celsius,
but about -2.
It's not much of a difference,
but it makes some difference.
And then there was this
definition, or this thing we
talked about, of supercooled
water, which happens
frequently in clouds in the
atmosphere, where you cool the
temperature down below the
freezing point, but yet the
water doesn't freeze
until something
triggers that freezing.
When freezing does occur, heat
is either well, for freezing
to occur, you have
to remove heat.
The reverse of that,
when you melt ice,
you have to add heat.
That is called the latent heat
of freezing, or the latent
heat of melting.
It's the same number,
either way.
And when you're condensing vapor
to form liquid, there's
a big heat required, depending
whether you're condensing or
evaporating.
So that's really important, and
then the saturation vapor
pressure, this idea that you
can keep more water in the
liquids--in the vapor state,
the hotter it is, is so
important for the atmosphere.
It explains why clouds
form, for example.
Rising air, adiabatic cooling,
eventually you come to the
saturation point and
then cloud liquid
water begins to form.
So water is a little more
complicated, maybe, than air,
because it gets in these
different phases and we really
have to understand how these
phase changes occur in order
to understand the atmosphere
ocean system.
Questions on that?
Hydrostatic balance is something
we've come across
over and over again.
It's the idea that when you go
up the way we derived it in an
incremental form is that if you
go up in the atmosphere a
height, delta z, move up from
there to there, the pressure
will decrease keep the minus
sign to remind me of that at a
rate that depends on the
acceleration of gravity and
the density of the fluid.
So we use that.
We came across that first in
atmospheres, but then it's
true in the oceans as well.
But remember, a typical density
in the atmosphere,
well it's 1.2 kilograms per
cubic meter at sea level.
But then it decreases strongly
as you go up.
So this value will change at
different altitudes in the
atmosphere.
In the ocean, it's about 1025.
It changes a bit around that
based on the salinity.
Same units, 1000
times greater.
When you get down
into the earth--
you can go down through
the earth's mantle--
this equation continues to be
valid, but there the density
is more like 2000 or 3000
kilograms per cubic meter.
So the pressure increases even
faster as you go down.
So the same equation can be
used in all three spheres.
But just remember, the density
can be all over the place.
From nearly zero, up in the top
of the atmosphere, to this
value at the surface, to this
value in the ocean, and this
value down in the interior
of the earth.
We also use that with
a barometer.
You know, the whole principle of
a mercury barometer is the
hydrostatic law.
That column of mercury rises to
a height needed to balance
the atmospheric pressure
pushing up at its base.
And so you see that principle
of hydrostatic
balance there as well.
Questions on hydrostatic?
Geostrophic balance,
another kind of
important force balance.
The idea there is that when
objects or fluids move
relative to the earth, they
have a Coriolis force.
And very often in the atmosphere
and the ocean,
after a few hours, you end up
in a state of geostrophic
balance, where the pressure
gradient force balances that
coriolis force.
And that gives some very
special properties.
It says that the air or the
water moves along the isobars
rather than across.
And the speed of the fluid is
proportional to the strength
of the pressure gradient.
Here's how we derive that.
We said that the pressure
gradient force was the product
of the pressure gradient and
the volume of some little
block of air that we imagined.
And then we equate that with the
Coriolis force, which was
2 times the mass, which is rho
times volume, times the
velocity of the object, times
the rotation rate of the earth
and the sine of the latitude.
So having equated those then
and solving for U, and
canceling out the volumes, I get
pressure gradient over 2
rho U omega sine phi for the
geostrophic--the speed of the
geostrophic wind.
And the direction of course
depends on the hemisphere, but
along the isobars.
Applies to both the atmosphere
and the ocean.
So any questions on that?
OK, now, this fifth item on the
list I've handed you is
the concept of equilibrium
states.
And I tried to get that started
in the early part of
the course by taking you
upstairs and doing this tank
experiment, where I had a
certain q in, and then I had a
q out that depended on the
depth of the water.
It depended on how much water
there was in the tank.
And we tried to understand the
equilibrium states of this
simple system.
And in a nutshell, this
is the way you do it.
If you make an axis--a plot like
this, with rates on this
axis, and some measure of the
amount of water in this case,
maybe it's the depth, z, on that
axis you can work out the
solution to this equilibrium
state graphically.
For example, if I'm putting a
certain amount of water into
this tank per unit, time, that
doesn't depend on how much
water I have in the tank.
This is just, you know, how much
water am I squirting into
the tank per unit time?
So that is a constant.
That's the rate of inflow.
But the rate of outflow will
depend on how much
water is in the tank.
The deeper the water, the more
pressure there is at the
bottom pushing water
through that valve.
And so if I make a plot here
of the outflow rate, versus
the depth of water in the
tank, it's going to look
something like this.
The deeper the water,
the faster the
water will gush out.
And there will be a crossing
point where the two are equal.
That's the equilibrium state.
Then the depth will remain
constant because the rate at
which we are putting fluid in
balances the rate at which
fluid is moving out.
That's what I mean by an
equilibrium state.
We saw this early
in the course.
Now let's see if some of the
ways that we have run across
this in the atmosphere
are perhaps
not appreciated enough.
For example, if we're
evaporating water from the
surface of the earth and putting
water vapor molecules
into the atmosphere, when we
get enough water in the
atmosphere, given the vertical
motions that are there from
convection, from fronts, and
so on, we're going to
eventually build up clouds.
And under some circumstances,
those clouds will precipitate.
And generally speaking, the
amount of water you take out
per unit time is going to be
related to how much water you
have in the atmosphere.
Well obviously, if you don't
have any water in the
atmosphere, you can't
take any out.
And if you've completely
saturated the atmosphere with
water, you're going to
be raining a lot out.
So there is some curve like
this, where, again, rate would
be on this axis.
This might be the water vapor
content of the atmosphere.
The rate at which we're putting
it in might depend a
little bit on water
vapor content.
But the rate at which we're
taking water out will
certainly depend on the
water vapor content.
And there will be a
crossover point.
So the amount of water vapor in
the atmosphere is going to
be sustained roughly at a level
where these two things
can balance with time.
And that's the way we think
about water vapor in the
atmosphere.
Let's do another one.
Heat in the climate system.
So the sun's radiation
is warming the earth.
If it had--if it was ice cold,
or if it were colder than ice,
if it were absolute zero
Kelvin, it would not be
radiating to space.
But it's not.
It's at some temperature, so
its radiating to space as
well, in relationship
to its temperature.
So if I make this plot again,
the rate will be the energy
from the sun absorbed
on the earth.
That's going to be independent
of the
temperature of the planet.
But the rate at which I'm
radiating to space is going to
be strongly dependent on the
temperature of the planet.
Remember, it goes like
t to the fourth.
The Stefan-Boltzmann law says
that this goes like
temperature to the
fourth power.
So there's some crossover
point.
And that's where we are most
of the time with the earth.
We're at an equilibrium state
set by seeking out this
balance between inflow
and outflow.
I'll do two more and then we'll
I don't want to beat
this too much to death but
it is so important.
If I had a what's next if I had
a mountain glacier, snow
falling on this glacier,
it's going to be
flowing under gravity.
So the rate at which I'm adding
snow to the top of this
is independent about how
much ice and snow
I have on the mountain.
That's just an atmospheric
thing, so the
input is just constant.
And this will be a measure.
Let's call this the thickness
of the glacier.
Thickness of the glacier.
If it's really thin, it's not
going to flow, and there's not
going to be any ice leaving
the system.
That is to say, running
down the mountainside.
But as it gets thicker, now
gravity is going to be pulling
that ice down away
from this region.
And that will be a
loss that will
increase with ice thickness.
The system will seek
out an equilibrium
where the snow falls.
You've reached a balance.
The amount of ice sliding down
the mountain is just equal
every year to how much
snow has fallen.
So you've reached
a steady-state
system for the glacier.
Now these glaciers are not
always in that steady state,
but this is one of the
possibilities we should always
investigate, to see whether
that system
is in steady state.
And the last one I had here was
the ozone layer, where you
remember far above the earth
there is this ozone layer.
You make ozone from oxygen.
You photosynthesize it and
recombine it differently to
make ozone.
So the rate at which you are
making ozone, for our intents
and purposes is pretty much
fixed, because you're not
going to change that
very much.
But the rate at which are
destroying ozone is going to
be proportional to how much
ozone you have. I showed you
that chemical reaction, also.
The more ozone you have, the
more chances that you'll
dissociate an ozone, combine
them in such a way that
removes ozone from the system.
So once again, you've got curves
generally like this.
The input's relatively
independent of how much ozone
you have. The loss rate is
proportional to how much ozone
you have. So there's going to
be a crossing point, and
that's going to be a
steady-state solution.
Again, I'm not claiming that the
earth's ozone layer is in
steady state, but that's one
possibility that we'd
want to look at.
And then if it's not, we'd want
to understand why there
are temporal changes going on.
Why has that system not yet
reached its steady state?
Questions there?
So this idea of lapse rate and
static stability, we ran
across for the ocean
and the atmosphere.
And for the atmosphere,
we did it this way.
We plotted temperature
versus height.
And we put reference lines
on there, which we
call capital gamma.
The dry adiabatic lapse rate was
about negative 9.8 degrees
Celsius per kilometer.
And we ran our reasoning about
whether an atmosphere would be
stable, just stay there in
layers, or whether it would
turn over and begin to
come back based on
this kind of an argument.
This is for the atmosphere.
For the ocean, we get a
little differently.
We plot in density versus
height or depth.
And we looked at various
possibilities.
Our reference line there
was really a
line of constant density.
If the density increased
as you went up,
that would be unstable.
If the density increased
as you went down,
that would be stable.
Why do we do the two
differently?
Well, the answer is clear.
For atmospheres we're dealing
with a compressible substance.
Gas is very compressible.
And so we had to work out this
adiabatic lapse rate, and do
the argument this way.
For water, it's incompressible
and it has the other
components.
It's got salinity
in it as well.
Remember density is a function
of temperature and
salinity in the ocean.
So the fact that it's
incompressible and the fact
that salinity is involved makes
us do the argument a
little bit differently.
But the question we're
asking is the same.
Is that column of fluid going to
stay stagnant in layers, or
is it going to turn
over and mix?
And that's important in
both spheres, the
atmosphere and the ocean.
Transport of heat
by fluid motion.
So we've come across this
several times, but the idea is
if you have a pipe, let's say
with fluid passing through it,
the volumetric flow rate
is a product of the
velocity and the area.
Now it doesn't have to be
confined in a pipe.
In the atmosphere or the ocean
it's not confined in a pipe.
But still it's the area and the
velocity that gives you
the volumetric flow rate.
The mass flow rate
would be rho U a.
The heat that you're pushing
through the pipe, well we got
the mass flow rate, and we know
that the amount of heat
stored per unit mass is C p T.
So this is heat capacity times
temperature times rho U A. If
that's water and you want know
how much salt is being
transported, well it's the
salinity times rho U A.
If it's some other pollutant,
like in the air, maybe it's
nitrous oxide, well then that
would be the concentration of
no2 times rho U A, if that
is a ratio by mass.
Be careful, be sure that's a
ratio by mass if you're going
to use it that way.
So anyway, this is a common
theme we ran across in the
atmosphere and the ocean.
And this is related to the next
one on the list, which is
the general idea of
concentration, where if you
put a substance and mix it into
a background fluid, we're
very interested in the
concentration, which is how
much did you put in, compared
to how much
you've mixed it into.
So for example, when I write
down, when I say this co2 in
brackets, I'm referring to the
concentration of carbon dioxide.
And that could be either the
mass of co2 over the mass of
air, or it could be the
molecules, the number of
molecules of co2 versus the
number of molecules of air.
So remember which one
you're dealing with.
Neither of these ratios has
units but you do have to
remember whether it's a mass
ratio or a molecular ratio.
This one is usually called "by
volume." And this one we would
say that's a ratio "by mass."
Taking into account by mass.
So you have to know how much
you put in, and into what
volume have you mixed it, and
the longer you wait for it to
mix into a larger and larger
volume, you have diluted it.
The same amount of material
added, but mixed into a larger
and larger amount, the
concentration will drop
because you're diluting it
into a larger background.
And that brings us to the last
one, which is this a question
that's always fascinated me
about the degree of symmetry
between the northern and
southern hemisphere.
So here we have our planet, our
home planet and it spins
in that direction.
And to what extent are the
northern and southern
hemispheres similar
or different?
Is there some kind of symmetry
between the northern and
southern hemispheres?
So I'll end up with a brief
discussion of this.
So we know that the seasons are
reversed between the two
hemispheres.
And that has to do with the
tilt of the earth, right?
So if the sun's over there, at
this moment the northern
hemisphere is tilted towards
well not at this moment.
At this moment, in December,
it's like that, right?
At this moment, the northern
hemisphere is tilted away from
the sun, southern hemisphere
towards.
So it's southern hemisphere
it's summer, and then six
months later, when the earth is
going around to the other
side of the sun,
it's like this.
And the northern hemisphere
has its summer.
So there's an opposite sense of
the timing of the seasons
between the two hemispheres.
What about the Coriolis
force and storms?
Well that's the opposite in
the two hemispheres, too.
But for a different reason.
It has nothing to do with
the tilt of the earth.
It has to do with the
spin of the earth.
The fact that it appears to spin
this way in the northern
hemisphere, but the opposite
direction in the southern
hemisphere.
So that cyclones move
counterclockwise in the
northern hemisphere, but
clockwise in the southern
hemisphere.
And that applies to the
atmosphere and the ocean.
Coreolis force is reverse
between the two.
Therefore, things just spin
differently in the two
hemispheres.
Now, are there any other
aspects of symmetry?
Well, one thing that's different
between the two
hemispheres is the
amount of land.
If you look at that one,
there's a fairly large
fraction of land.
I want to get this base
out of the way, so
I'll do it this way.
If you look at it that way,
there's much less land.
And as we know, land and ocean
have different heat storage
capabilities.
The ocean can store heat
powerfully, because not only
does it have a high specific
heat capacity, C p, but also,
when you heat, put heat at the
top of the ocean, it mixes it
in, because it's a fluid.
So you may have to mix heat.
Heat can be stored easily in the
first hundred meters or so
of the ocean, and that's
an enormous mass.
Where when I had heat to a
continent, it only goes in
about that much.
Or maybe over a season, between
winter and summer, it
will go in about that much.
As compared to 100 meters
for the ocean.
So the heat storage capacity is
very different between land
and sea, and the northern
hemisphere has much more land
than the southern hemisphere.
So there's going to be that
asymmetry between the two.
And there's also a little
different configuration, I
want to remind you,
near the poles.
When it comes to this
question of Arctic
sea ice, for example.
The Arctic Ocean is a little
it's an ocean surrounded by
land, whereas in the southern
hemisphere, it's land
surrounded by ocean, right?
So this interaction between
the ocean and the land is
quite different at the high
latitudes in the two
hemispheres.
For example, Antarctic bottom
water, which is water formed
near the Antarctic coast, the
densest water in the sea drops
down to the bottom and
flows northward.
There's no equivalent to that
in the northern hemisphere,
because that geometry
is different.
So these are fundamental ideas
and I think I'll leave it
there, and thank you and good
luck on the final exam.